in this video you're going to learn how
to solve quadratic equations by
completing the square and we're going to
talk about all the steps that you're
going to need to do to do this process
we're going to go through two examples
one easier one one slightly more
challenging so let's dive in so the
first one we've got x^2 - 4x + 2al 0 so
following these steps you might want to
take a screenshot or write these down
the first step I like to think about it
as moving the constant to the other side
of the equation what do I mean by that
well the constant is just the number so
we want to get this to the other side
basically just to get it out of the way
so we're going to subtract two from both
sides and so that gives us x^2 - 4x = -2
okay now step number two you want to
divide everything by the leading
coefficient or you could think of it as
the a value like ax s the number that
comes in front of the x s term in this
case you can see this is understood to
be a one if I divide everything by one
it's going to be a self so I really
don't need to do that in this particular
problem but we'll do it in the next one
for step number three now you want to
figure out what B divided two the
quantity squared is and add that to both
sides this is key step in completing the
square so the BV value is the number
that comes in front of X okay so we're
going to say H half of -4 or it could
say4 divid two let's do it over here on
the side sometimes that helps squared
so4 / 2 is -2 2^2 is
4 and so what we're going to do is we're
going to add four to the left side of
the equation and the right side of the
equation to keep it balanced we don't
want to change the equation we just want
to change the way that it
looks now for step number four we want
to factor the perfect square trinomial
that we created on the left side here of
the equation and when you do this just a
little hint it's going to be a perfect
square a binomial squared and it's
always going to be half of this B value
so if this was +4 I would write plus2 2
since it's -4 I'm going to write min-2
always half of that b value and over
here -2 + 4 is 2 so now we've completed
the square but we want to solve it by
taking the square root of both sides and
remember when you take the square root
of both sides of the equation you get
two answers plus or minus positive or
negative so let's go ahead and do that
now we're going to take the square root
of the left side square root of the
right side the square and the square
root they undo one another so we're left
with x - 2 = plus or minus the > two now
a lot of teachers will have you do the
step number six about splitting it into
two equations and then solving and the
way you would do that is you would write
one equation where x - 2 is equal to
positive2 and another equation where x -
2 is equal
tok2 and then all you have to do now is
solve so I'm going to add two to both
sides add two to both
sides and we get X is = 2 +
2 and 2 - 2 and those are your two
solutions now a little shortcut if
you're interested is you could add this
two but just make sure you put it in
front of the plus or minus sign so there
would be a positive2 plus or minus < tk2
a little bit quicker but a lot of times
teachers will have you split it let's
look at another example okay for number
two now we've got 3x^2 - 24x + 9 is
equal to Zer keep in mind that this is
in the form a x^2 + BX + c = z okay so
when we talk about our A and B uh and C
that's what we're referring to so let's
go through the steps if you want to
pause the video and try this on your own
you can definitely do that it says move
the constant to the other side of the
equation the constant is the C value
right here it's just this number so what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
subtract nine from both sides to keep
the equation
balanced and so we're left here on the
left with 3x^2 - 24x = 9 okay so now
step number
two we want to divide everything by the
leading coefficient or the a value
that's the number that comes in front of
the X squ term so if we divide
everything by three we're keeping the
equation Balan because we're doing it to
both sides this is going to give us x^2
- 8X is equal to
-3 now number three we take half of the
B value squared or we can think of it as
B / 2 the quantity squared and we're
going to add it to both sides to keep
the equation balanced so the B is a
number that comes in front of the X here
that's 8 and so let's do the work over
here on the side8 / 2 squared well
that's -4 -4 SAR is a positive
16 and we're going to add 16 to the left
side and the right side now we're going
to go to step number four we're going to
factor the perfect square square
trinomial that we ourselves created here
okay by completing the square and the
way that that factors remember it's
always going to be half of this B value
so this is going to be minus 4 x -4
thean squared if it was Plus 8 it would
be +4 you can check your work if you
take this binomial and you multiply it
by itself so x - 4 * x - 4 would give
you back the quantity here okay and this
is equal to 13 now we're going to take
the square root of both sides
remembering the plus or
minus to solve it so if we take the
square to the left we want to take the
square of the right again remember we
get two answers plus or minus square of
13 the square and the square root undo
one another and now all we have to do is
split this into two equations and solve
step number six or if you want to use my
shortcut you can add four just make sure
you add the four in front of the plus or
minus because it's not really plus or
minus square of 13 + 4 it's 4 +un 13 and
4 minus < tk13 so that would be
final uh two solutions if you want to
get a decimal you can do this on your
calculator and then combine them
together this is an exact answer if you
like the way that I explain things and
you want to see more about completing
the square follow me over to that video
I did right there we'll get some more
practice you can test yourself and I'll
see you over in that video